hey youtubers is Charlie so there's
gonna be my top 10 episodes of the flash
season 1 originally I started it out as
like a top 5 list but then I realized I
was leaving so many episodes out that
were amazing I just ballooned it to 10
there are a whole bunch of reasons why
the flash is one of the best comic book
shows on TV right now
most notably the strength of its actors
its villain in particular Tom Cavanagh
he played like three or four different
characters in this season there's the
strength of its writers room led by
Andrew Kreisberg I actually heard one of
the writers say that they have this
motto that they go by when they're
conceiving of storylines like whenever
they go to pitch for characters or write
scripts humor heart and spectacle it's
like the the three guiding things you
know in that order of importance also a
huge strike in his favor is that all the
writers and a lot of people that work on
the show are huge comic book fans
especially of the flash and Geoff Johns
is you know somewhat on staff I mean
he's creative advisor but most of the
material that they draw from in the
comics is from Geoff Johns run so it's
like they're able to go straight to the
source and really that's what it's all
about getting the characters right that
that's really what geoff johns does on
all the movies and the TV shows so here
we go top 10 episodes starting with
number 10 rogue time this was the second
part of the two part time travel episode
you know in the middle of the second
half of the season it's Barry's
groundhogs day he learns all about time
travel from Harrison wells it did a
great job of telling that in a really
funny but kind of scary Terminator way
like you might cause the future
apocalypse if you go back and change
anything but they also have that nice
joke with weather wizard threatening to
you know bring a big tidal wave on the
city which is exactly what he did in the
original timeline as much as the first
part of that episode you know I
considered like a two-part episode but I
broke them apart on this list the second
part this episode rogue time is all
about Cisco it's like a really strong
Cisco episode Cisco gives up Barry's
identity to save his brother and you
know even though they hate each other
that's the heart of the episode he
really loves his family he says he's
never gonna do it again he never wants
to put himself in that situation where
he might give his friends up but they
won't let him either so you know it just
goes to show you that cisco has his
nuclear family like his original family
and he has his team flash family on to
number nine who is Harrison wells this
is one of the more fun episodes like you
know the body-swapping episode even
though there's a pretty notable villain
we you know we have Hannibal Bates in
the episode
the strength I think in this episode is
is the humor as it plays on the
relationship between members of team
flash you go from Barry kissing Caitlin
and the in the awkwardness that that
causes to Barry beating the crap out of
iris West that was a lot of fun just
letting them do that
using the body swap to have some fun
with that it kind of makes you wonder
how the real iris West would do in a
fistfight although she did clock
peek-a-boo with the fire extinguisher on
to number 8 revenge of the Rogues this
is the illustrious return of Captain
Cold and heat wave after they've become
the Rogues it's like a direct follow-up
to Captain Cold stab you in episode 4
I'm putting a team together are you in
and you know he gives heatwave his gun
suddenly the whole episodes turns into
this really fun Prison Break reunion
with them just going to town on the city
so it's a lot of fun because it's right
out of the comics very eating blast from
both guns at the same time you know some
great visual effects and that scene the
pathos of both characters like we get to
know heatwave a little bit more who's
absolutely crazy but that's how he is in
the comics so Dominic Purcell
performance is fairly authentic to the
heatwave of the comics and it does a
good job of addressing villain decay
remember at the end of episode 4 Captain
Cold got away with both guns villain
decay is that thing that you know
unfortunately sometimes happens when
villains that you can't beat in an
episode come back in an episode later
much much weaker they're much easier for
the heroes to beat at the end of this
episode we learned that getting caught
was all part of Captain colds plan so
even though it looked like he lost that
was just part of the plan on to number 7
the first episode the pilot I can't say
enough about the strength of the flash
pilot there were some things that you
could tell that they were still figuring
out like the special effects the special
effects got way better over the course
of the season but they're just like a
few really important things that they
did in this episode that laid a really
strong foundation they just help them
build momentum from episode 1 to episode
23 and that's really what you want to do
you don't want to have like a really
strong build up the first half of the
season and then just have things fall
apart in the back half you know with the
lackluster finale just like gradually
ratcheting up the WTF but what they did
is is they used the mystery behind the
murder of Barry's mother as the backbone
for the entire season the whole season I
mean he says it in the intro every
single episode I'm going to find out who
killed my
mother and get justice for my father so
regardless of like you know which
villains come each week you know what
new problems happen it's all about
finding out who killed his mother and
getting justice for his father but on to
number six the flash vs. arrow the
illustrious flare oh this is a big deal
for very obvious reasons
big TV crossovers like big event-based
crossovers are really hard to do what
the arrow and the flash people are doing
you know the burl ante productions
people the people that make all these
shows are trying to do is create a comic
book universe in the same way that they
do big event based comics during the
summer like you have DC's convergence
you have Marvel Secret Wars and they all
form this giant meta mega story so if
you're really pumped about legends of
tomorrow that's spin-off show you can
thank Flair oh and what it allows you to
do is have some fun with the characters
in a way that you normally wouldn't in
their own environment so like the arrow
characters get to be a lot funnier they
get to have a lot more fun when they're
in Central City but on to number five
the man in the yellow suit that the
mid-season finale already said the Tom
Cavanagh in the way that the reverse
flash is written is one of the things
that makes the flash one of the best
comic book shows on TV right now and
this episode is all about him like it
brings him to the forefront
you know steps out of the shadows we get
some amazing comic book references like
we get the flash ring one of the most
iconic aspects of the flash costume we
learn definitively that there is a wolf
in the henhouse the person we've trusted
all season is the villain of the series
very heavy on the heart very heavy on
the spectacle barry renews his mission
to find the man in yellow but he knows
he's not strong enough in the stakes
just keep getting bigger and bigger and
bigger we've been at this a long time I
always win merry freaking Christmas on
to number 4 out of time this took like
the flare Oh Spartacus crossovers to a
new level I mean you know arrow casts a
lot of Spartacus characters now that
flash does to the episode gives us time
travel and some really badass visual
effects seriously like I mean we've
gotten some great firestorm effects but
this took it to like a whole new level
we have someone that can make a giant
tidal wave and it pushes Barry so fast
so hard that he punches a hole in
time-space so not only where the stakes
really high emotionally like the payoff
was huge compared
by the fact that Cisco died that was
probably like the most emotional scene
all year
next to Barry saying goodbye to his
mother in the finale on to number three
so this is kind of like a tie between
two episodes they just couldn't you know
find a way to separate them so we have
the nuclear man the firestorm episode
the first big firestorm episode and
Grodd lives if you saw any of the
firestorm episodes this season you
understand what a big deal it is having
that character on screen and what it
means for future characters that they
can bring on if they can do that you
know they can do just about anything I
know there's some issues with the movies
but but literally there are thousands of
DC characters that are all really
amazing Robbie Amell and Victor Garber
were just the icing on the cake
seriously if you every big fan of Victor
Garber go back and watch him on alias
Robbie Amell of course just a whole lot
of fun to watch especially after the
Tomorrow People which was also another
Greg Berlanti series it took a little
while to get both of the emails
on-screen but they eventually did that
too so you know it's just a fun meta
thing talking gorilla grodd is the I am
Groot of television this year think
about the impact of Groot in guardians
of the galaxy you know and culturally
what that meant the most popular
character in a movie last year was a
talking tree how awesome is it that that
is completely ridiculous the same thing
is true of television and Grodd you know
fraction of the budget but who would
think that a gorilla would be so amazing
conceptually it just sounds like it
ended up super silly but they actually
you know guardians of the galaxy
reference here to the person that voices
Gorilla Grodd that does the voice forum
also voices Drax the destroyer on the
guardians of the galaxy cartoon so just
a nice crossing of the streams there
everybody hold out hope for gorilla City
and just just think of the Sisko Planet
of the Apes jokes ah number two
tricksters Mark Hamill's episode this is
another one of those gorilla grodd type
moments never thought we would live to
see it on television
Mark Hamill of course one of the busiest
actors in television right now he does
so much voiceover work
he's the freakin Joker and he's
reprising his role in the Star Wars
universe too so he's gone big again but
the thing that really made this episode
was how meta and compelling his
performance was as the trickster this is
like a laundry list of the interactions
going on you have him on screen with the
original flash John Wesley Shipp just
like they did on the original series and
the episodes that they were in
he's reprising
his original character from that TV
series that nobody working on the flash
worked on like that was a completely
different crew and they managed to drop
as many Star Wars references as possible
I am your father
almost every single show on television
makes a Star Wars joke at some point but
to get Mark Hamill to get Luke Skywalker
to do a Darth Vader line that sets the
bar so much higher I don't know how
they're going to top that but I'm sure
they will and finally my number one
episode the finale not a lot of shows
can say they nailed the landing the way
the flash did it started out with the
mystery behind Barry's mother's murder
and traveled in a full circle like
things came full circle Barry went back
to that moment and in doing so kind of
gave birth to the TV multiverse you get
a big payoff because the villain goes
down and he does so with a heroic
sacrifice from someone who could have
taken a dramatic left turn to become a
villain himself you know Eddie and we
learned that the timeline that we've
been in all season is actually an
alternate timeline the original timeline
was that first one the Barry with the
white flash emblem this whole season has
been the alternate timeline so they
leave the show in a really strong foot
to start off season two especially you
know what the idea of the multiverse and
what's going to happen now that there's
this big time vortex getting ready to
eat the earth the Easter Egg the at
a Jay Garrick and rip hunter which leads
into legends of tomorrow so they're
starting to integrate the other shows in
a more meaningful way and all throughout
it they've been really upfront about the
storylines they're going to be working
on the characters are bringing on look
at you know mirror master they showed us
Caitlin snow as killer frost all things
that they're going to deliver on I'm
sure after I you know watch the episodes
like 10 or 15 more times I'll reorder my
list but here's my big question for you
guys what are your favorite episodes of
the flash here's another question -
which characters like which big
characters do you want to see come back
like do you want to see Mark Hamill come
back really big actors like that that
are tied up with franchises or a little
a little harder to pin down but if
you're only looking to get like eight
days out of them it's a little bit
easier really what we need to think
about now is is you know how is the
legends of tomorrow storyline going to
influence the flash season to storyline
because now we're in a time travel which
can be really confusing but but the
flash writers are always really good at
explaining themselves you know via the
characters like Cisco for instance he's
kinda like the explainer character
I feel like as long as like they they
pick their time travel logic and they're
consistent in that it'll be an amazing
season
so here's what's going on this week you
know a lot of you requested some
specific videos I am working on a
Suicide Squad video I'll do that
tomorrow along with another arrow bonus
video so I'll probably do I also have to
do a mirror master video so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff
mirror master might end up being next
week but there's just a whole bunch
other stuff that I plan on doing videos
for so if you have any special requests
just leave them in the comments just in
case you guys didn't see it I just did a
big Bucky Captain America Civil War
video you can click here to learn all
about that he's going to be a big part
of that movie and you can click here for
my flash season 2 predictions thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you